what do you think about like the future
of like jobs and stuff do you feel like
we're in a scary spot do you feel like
that's just hype that we're in a scary
spot no we're in a scary spot
we're in a scary spot
two things first of all
yeah
the visuals will Define you it doesn't
matter what you say it doesn't matter
how hard you work some people have a
difficult time
um processing it right it's hard to see
people as more than one thing sometimes
too it's like our brain just wants to
make it easy on ourselves that's right
you know what can I what can I assume
from a guy with a haircut like yours a
ball cap a vest
a t-shirt you know the honest answer is
freaking nothing there's nothing to
assume at all but I'm trained to make
all kinds of assumptions yeah and and so
that thing is alive in our culture and
it's alive in our Workforce and it's
it's just bitching everything up because
people simply can't
they they just can't process the
cognitive dissonance of it uh the other
thing is yeah we're we're in real
trouble
um I had a guy on my podcast uh just a
couple weeks ago an economist named uh
Nicholas Everhart okay this guy is
brilliant Harvard all the abbreviations
after his name that you want uh American
Enterprise Institute wrote a
best-selling book in 2016 called men
without work just republished it because
the contention in the book is now on
steroids wow and basically what he's
saying is
never mind the unemployment numbers they
don't matter that's a Depression era
metric and it doesn't tell us anything
we really really need to know here's
what we need to know 7 million
able-bodied men between the ages of 25
and 54 are not only not working
they are not looking they're
affirmatively not looking for work never
in the in in peace time
never has that metric existed before we
have four million more open jobs today
than we did pre-pandemic and we have
four million fewer people in the
workforce
it's really bad and you can't find an
employer
in anywhere today who is not
desperate to hire so like that that's
actually happening so some of the things
that I hear when I'm out and about you
know
um you hear from some people that
they're not paying enough right oh sure
um and then you hear from other people
that if they weigh if they raise the
minimum wage in some job and some uh
businesses then it'll kill the business
sure
um I think greed is also probably a big
problem that's happened in this country
it's like we don't you don't want the
man who's working with you to also have
success at some point it's like it's
exactly what we just said about two
things being true at the same time and
people
struggling with it
um it is
it is true that lots and lots of people
are out of work uh it is true that even
more people
aren't looking for work if I tell you
that there are 11 million open jobs in
the country right now that's not
political that's just a fact yeah and no
one can dispute it no one does dispute
it but what immediately happens is my
buddies on the left to your point when I
say why do you think there's so much
opportunity here that can't be filled
they'll say because
because business owners are Pricks
they're greedy and they're rapacious and
if they paid more money those jobs would
fill
my buddies on the right when I ask him
the same question will say because
people are lazy people are just lazy
they don't want to work they won't show
up early they won't stay late they won't
take a bite of the [ __ ] sandwich when
it's their turn they won't do the thing
that needs to be done
so
that's how it becomes politicized it
doesn't change the fact that there's
still 11 million open jobs but if we
want to argue that the jobs are open
because the opportunities are shitty
versus the jobs are open because people
don't want to work
then we're going to paint with a really
broad brush and we're not going to solve
the problem
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one